Você acorda de manhã, pega aquele
suplemento de vitamina C de dose 500 mg,
toma religiosamente pensando que está
fazendo tudo certo pra sua imunidade,
né? Pois é, meu amigo, minha amiga, hoje
eu vou te mostrar porque que essa dose
provavelmente é insuficiente para o que
realmente importa. E olha, eu não estou
falando só de gripe resfriada, estou
falando de uma coisa bem mais séria que
está destruindo seu corpo por dentro
agora mesmo. Extremamente comum, tá?
Quase ninguém tá sofrendo isso, né?
Cortisol elevado, inflamação celular
crônica. E tem um estudo de 2024 que
chegou com dados bombásticos, mostrando
que 2000 mg, também conhecido com 2 g de
vitamina C, podem literalmente modular
esse processo no nível molecular. Fica
comigo que nos próximos minutos você vai
entender porque a maioria das pessoas
está subestimando completamente esse
nutriente. E por que que o Linus Pauling
tava tão certo de fato, deixa te contar
uma coisa que eu aprendi depois de 27
anos atendendo o paciente atrás de
paciente no consultório. 27 não, né? Tá
indo para 29 já. Sabe aquele cara que
chega dizendo que está estressado,
cansado o tempo todo, engordando sem
parar, dormindo mal, com libido baixo?
Nove em cada 10 casos, quando a gente
vai investigar a fundo, o cortisol tá
nas alturas.
E aqui está o pulo do gato, que a
medicina ortodoxa geralmente ignora.
suas glândulas suprarrenais ou adenais,
aquelas duas bolinhas em forma de
pirâmide em cima dos ins. Preciso de
vitamina C para fabricar cortisol e
adrenalina.
Mas aqui entra o problema. Quanto mais
estressado você fica, mais cortisol seu
corpo produz e mais vitamina C é
queimada no processo. É tipo um carro
desgovernado descendo ladeira abaixo.
Agora, presta atenção nesse dado que
saiu de 2024.
Um estudo publicado no Stress Medicine
Journal pegou 69 mulheres com
hipercortisolemia
funcional, aquele cortisol alto causado
por estresse crônico, dividiram em
grupos e um deles recebeu 1000 mg de
vitamina C por dia durante 2 meses. E o
resultado? O cortisol caiu de 780
nanomoles por litro para 446.
Isso é uma redução de 43%,
cara, quase metade. E olha que
interessante, no grupo que tinha
cortisol e da na forma de sulfato, ou
seja, deidroepandros assofatado elevados
juntos, a queda foi de 657 para 515, uma
redução de 21%. Então, não é placebo,
não é pilô de farinha, não é efeito
psicológico, é bioquímica pura
acontecendo dentro das suas células. Mas
você deve estar se perguntando como que
diabos uma vitamina consegue fazer isso?
Bem, vamos entrar na parte técnica aqui,
mas eu vou explicar de um jeito que você
vai entender, você vai sacar. dentro das
suas glândulas suprarrenais tem uma
concentração de vitamina C que é de 10 a
100 vezes maior do que no sangue. Isso
mesmo que você ouviu. Suas suprarrenais
concentram vitamina C de propósito,
acumulando contra o gradiente de
concentração. E por que que faz isso?
Porque ela é cofator essencial para as
enzimas que produzem seus hormônios do
estresse. Se vitamina C suficiente,
essas enzimas trabalham devagar. o
sistema começa a desregular e você entra
naquela espiral de fadiga adrenal que
tanto se fala por aí. E tem mais uma
camada nessa história que é fascinante.
A vitamina C não atua só na produção do
cortisol, ela também modula resposta
inflamatória no nível celular através da
imbição do NFK beta. Esse nome esquisito
aí é um fator de transcrição nuclear,
basicamente um interruptor genético que
quando ativado dispara a produção de
citocinas pró-inflamatórias. Sabe
aquelas substâncias que fazem você se ti
dor inchaço? febre. Então, um estudo
publicado em 2023 na revista
Biomedicines mostrou que doses altas de
vitamina Cem inibir essa via do NFK
beta, reduzindo dramaticamente a
produção de terleucina 6, terleucina 1,
TNF alfa, todas essas moléculas
inflamatórias que estão te destruindo
silenciosamente.
trabalho de metanálise 2022 que analisou
18 estudos randomizados e controlados
por placebo. 322 pessoas no total
encontrou algo revelador. Quando os
participantes tomaram vitaminas C e E
combinadas, antes de fazer exercício
físico intenso, houve redução
significativa na peroxidação lipídica,
que é quando os radicais livres atacam
as gorduras das suas membranas
celulares. Mas o dado que me chamou
atenção foi esse. A suplementação
reduziu os níveis de telucina 6 em 57%
e os níveis de cortisol foram atenuados
em 91%
imediatamente após o exercício. Isso
mostra que a vitamina C não está só
agindo na produção do cortisol pelas
suprarrenais. Ela também tá modulando a
resposta inflamatória sistêmica, que
estimula ainda mais a liberação de
cortisol. Agora você pode estar
pensando, mas doutor a dose recomendada
não é tipo 90 mg por dia? Sim, essa é
chamada RDA, que é a dose diária
recomendada que foi estabelecida lá na
década de 1940.
E para quê? Para prevenir escorbuto, a
doença dos marinheiros, né?
Então essa doença era aquela que os
marinheiros tinham quando ficavam meses
no mar sem comer fruta fresca. A gente
tá falando aqui de prevenir uma doença
de deficiência grave, mas será que a
dose para não morrer de escorbuto é a
mesma dose para ter saúde ótima, para
modular inflamação, para regular
cortisol? Claro que não, né? É como
comparar a quantidade mínima de água que
você precisa para não morrer de sede ou
de hidratação com a quantidade ideal
para ter performance atlética. Não tem
nada a ver uma coisa com a outra. E olha
só esse dado, interessante. Um estudo
alemão de 2006 pegou 120 pessoas,
submeteu elas a um teste psicológico
estressante, falar em público combinado
com fazer contas matemáticas difíceis na
frente de todo mundo. Imagina isso, né?
Eu ia me ferrar. Metade tomou 1000 mg de
vitamina C antes, metade não tomou nada.
E o resultado, o grupo sem suplementação
mostrou picos muito maiores de cortisol
e pressão arterial. e relataram sentir
muito mais estresse subjetivo. Então, o
grupo suplementado teve resposta muito
mais branda e se recuperou mais rápido.
A vitamina C literalmente amorteceu a
resposta ao estresse agudo. Mas aqui
está o detalhe que poucos profissionais
te contam. A vitamina C é hidrossolúvel,
o que significa que seu corpo não estoca
ela. Se você toma 100 mg de manhã,
algumas horas depois seus níveis já
estão caindo. Durante situações de
estresse intenso, infecção, inflamação,
exercício pesado, seus tecidos consomem
vitamina C numa velocidade absurda. Um
estudo de 2025 publicado no Frontiers e
Nutrition, analisando pacientes UTI com
sepse e lesão renal aguda, mostrou que a
deficiência vitamina C é extremamente
prevalente nesses pacientes críticos e a
suplementação durante a internação
melhorou a sobrevida em 28 dias. Por
quê? Porque o consumo aumenta
drasticamente durante o estress
metabólico severo. Então vamos falar de
doses práticas. Agora, a literatura
científica atual trabalha com doses que
variam de 1000 a 2000 mg por dia, também
conhecido como 1 a 2 g, para efeitos
anti-inflamatórios e modulação de
cortisol. O estudo armênio de 2024 que
eu te contei usou 1 g e já viu redução
de 35 a 43% no cortisol. Outros estudos
sobre estresse oxidativo e marcadores
inflamatórios pós exercício usam de 1 a
3 g ao dia. O limite superior
estabelecido por Autoridade de Saúde é
2000 mg por dia. Acima disso, você pode
ter desconforto gastestinal, pode ter
diarreia, mas são algumas pessoas, não
são todos. Tem gente que tolera bem
doses maiores, mas depende de tudo da
tolerância individual intestinal. E aqui
entra uma estratégia que eu uso muito na
minha prática clínica, dividir a dose ao
longo do dia. O pessoal se esquece, mas
é uma ótima estratégia. Então, se você
vai tomar 2000 mg, toma 500 no café da
manhã, 500 no almoço, 500 no lanche, 500
à noite. E por que isso? Porque a
absorção intestinal da vitamina C é
saturável. Quando você toma 1 g, 1000 mg
de uma vez, a absorção fica em torno de
50%. Quando você toma em doses menores,
divide em doses menores, a absorção
percentual aumenta. Além disso, você
mantém níveis plasmáticos no sangue mais
estáveis ao longo do dia todo, o que é
exatamente o que você quer quando está
tentando modular inflamação crônica e
resposta ao estresse. E não podemos
esquecer da qualidade da vitamina C que
você tá consumindo. Tem vitamina C
sintética pura, tem vitamina C com
bioflavonoides que é bacana, tem formas
tamponadas com minerais, tipo ascorbato
de cálcio, ascorbato de magnésio, são
menos ácidas pro estômago. Pessoalmente,
eu prefiro as formas que vêm com
bioflavonoides, porque potencializam
ação antioxidante, tem propriedades
antiflamatórias próprias. É como você
tomar um comitê junto de auxílio, mas se
você tem estômago sensível, as formas
tamponadas são uma boa pedida, porque
não irrito tanto a mucosa do estômago.
Agora vou te contar um caso real que eu
atendi faz alguns meses. Paciente 42
anos, homem executivo, chegou num
consultório com queixa de fadiga
crônica, ganho de peso progressivo,
apesar de estar malhando todo dia,
irritabilidade insônia. Eu pedi cortisol
salivá de quatro pontos. e deu aquele
padrão clássico, só alto de manhã, alto
de tarde, alto de noite, não conseguia
desligar nunca. Dos amos vitamina C s c
sérca estava baixíssima, 0,3 mg por dcl,
quando o ideal é acima de 0,6. Nem sei
protocolo, 2000 mg de vitamina C
divididos em longo do tempo, quatro
tomadas, mais magnésio, mais
adaptógenos. Depois de 8 semanas,
repetimos os exames. O cortisol já tinha
normalizado de maneira significativa.
Ele relatou melhora brutal do sono, mais
exposição,
começou a emagrecer naturalmente. E
olha, não foi só a vitamina C, foi o
protocolo completo, óbvio, mas ela foi
uma peça interessante, fundamental da
engrenagem. Mas aqui está o pulo do gato
que eu preciso te passar. Vitamina C não
funciona isolada no vácuo, óbvio, ela
trabalha em sinergia com outros
nutrientes. Vitamina E regenera a
vitamina C oxidado ascorbil,
transformando ela de volta na
formaativa. O magnésio é cofator de
várias enzimas que usam vitamina C. O
zinco potencializa os efeitos
antioxidantes. Quando você monta um
protocolo antioxidante, antiinflamatório
completo, os efeitos são
exponencialmente maiores do que você só
usar uma substância isolada. Por isso
que na minha prática clínica eu sempre
trabalho com protocolos cinéticos, nunca
com uma coisinha isolada. E tem uma
coisa que pouquíssimos profissionais
falam, mas que precisa ser dita. A fonte
da vitamina C importa muito. Vitamina C
de frutas e vegetais vem junto com
milhares de outros fitonutrientes,
modulam a absorção, a utilização celular
e a reciclagem. Então, el tem um estudo
publicado muito interessante, 2025,
comparou a capacidade de aliviar colite
induzida experimentalmente entre
vitamina C pura e extrato de rosa Hburg,
uma fruta extremamente rica em vitamina
C. O extrato da fruta foi
significativamente mais eficaz,
provavelmente porque além da vitamina C
tem polifenóis juntos, tem antocianinas,
tem uma matriz toda de compostos
bioativos. Então, idealmente você
combina a suplementação com alimentação
rica em fontes naturais. Aí tá top.
Outro ponto crucial que eu preciso
mencionar, a vitamina C tem meia vida
curta no organismo. Muita gente sabe
disso. Em condições de estresse,
inflamação, doença, essa minha vida
diminui ainda mais, porque o consumo
tecido aumenta. Por isso, protocolos bem
desenhados usam doses divididas ao longo
do dia, múltiplas vezes ao dia. Tem
gente que até usa vitamina C lipossomal,
que tem absorção diferenciada e atinge
concentrações intracelulares maiores com
doses menores. Existem várias
estratégias. O importante é entender a
fármacocinética, a fármacodinâmica do
nutriente para usar de forma
inteligente. Agora vou te dar uma visão
que falta na maioria das orientações por
aí. O cortisol não é vilão não, pessoal.
Ele é importante, ele é essencial pra
vida. O problema é o cortisol
cronicamente elevado e desregulado.
Também pode acontecer dele baixar e
ficar super baixo. E a inflamação também
não é vilã por si só. Ela é uma resposta
de defesa necessária. O organismo
precisa disso para se defender. O
problema é inflamação crônica de baixo
grau e que não resolve nunca. A vitamina
C entra como um modulador inteligente
nesse processo. Ela não bloqueia
completamente, ela regula, equilibra.
Isso éem medicina de precisão. É
entender a bioquímica e usar os
nutrientes certos nas dosees certas para
restaurar homeostase. E olha, eu não
estou dizendo que vitamina C sozinha vai
resolver todos os seus problemas de
estresse, inflamação. Seria muita
pretensão minha afirmar isso. Mas o que
que a ciência mostra de forma cristalina
é que ela é uma ferramenta poderosa
dentro de uma abordagem integrativa mais
ampla. Você precisa de trabalhar o sono,
alimentação, exercício, gerenciamento
emocional de estresse, óbvio, né,
pessoal, possivelmente também vários
outros suplementos, mas subestimar o
papel da vitamina C em doses adequadas é
jogar fora uma arma importante e barata
de modo geral do seu arsenal
terapêutico.
Uma revisão abrangente publicada em
fevereiro de 2025 na revista Moléculos
consolidou décadas de pesquisa sobre
vitamina C e seu papel na saúde,
prevenção de doenças e potencial
terapêutico. O artigo reforça que desde
descoberta por Zent George e seu uso no
tratamento do escorbuto, a vitamina C
continua sendo objeto de intenso
interesse científico devido a suas
propriedades únicas como cofator na
síntese de colágeno e hormônios. Seu
papel na imunidade, absorção de ferro e
processos antioxidantes. A revisão
destaca a importância da vitamina C para
melhorar a qualidade de vida e prevenir
doenças crônicas, cardiovasculares e
câncer, além de seu uso terapêutico em
infecções, doenças neurodegenerativas.
Então, resumindo tudo aqui para você, se
você está lidando com estress crônico,
fadiga, inflamação persistente, sintomas
que sugerem desregulação do cortisol,
dose de vitamina C na faixa de 1000 a
2000 mg por dia, divididos ao longo do
dia, tenta tomar pelo menos quatro vezes
por dia, podem fazer uma diferença
substancial. Não é megadose, não é
terapiaolécular maluca, apesar que isso
existe também, né, mas não é assunto
desse vídeo. É um uso racional baseado
em evidências sólidas da literatura
científica atual. Você está dando pro
seu corpo o substrato bioquímico que ele
precisa para modular a resposta o
estresse e controlar a inflamação de
nível celular. E os estudos de 24 e 25
só reforçam ainda mais esse conceito com
dados cada vez mais robustos.
Agora é o momento de sair do vídeo. Se
você gosta de ficar na superficial, eu
vou te contar uma verdade muito
inconveniente. O YouTube e também um
conselho de medicina me limitam aqui. Eu
preciso simplificar, censurar dosagens,
omitir protocolos controversos. E na
nossa comunidade fechada não existe
filtro. Eu compartilho os exatos
protocolos que eu uso na minha clínica.
Casos de reversão que pareciam
impossíveis, combinações of label que
funcionam, além de forneciadores
confiáveis e interpretação avançada de
exames. É basicamente ter acesso ao meu
cérebro médico sem intermediários, lives
semanais respondendo perguntas, PDF com
47 protocolos exclusivos, grupo no
WhatsApp. Se você quer a visão funcional
real, sem simplificação para as massas,
clique em seja membro. Não é para
curiosos, é para quem quer resultados.
Agora, se você quer ir ainda mais fundo,
existe um nível dois. A cada duas
semanas, fazemos live de imersão total
com 2 horas de duração, desse artigos
científicos linha por linha, debatendo
controvérsias que ninguém ousa tocar,
revelando os bastidores das pesquisas
que a indústria não quer que você
entenda. E tem mais, o seu nome será
mencionado nos vídeos como
agradecimento. Você se torna parte
visível dessa comunidade de elite que
está reescrevendo as regras da medicina.
Enquanto a maioria assiste passivamente,
você estará ao meu lado construindo
conhecimento de verdade, tendo o seu
reconhecimento público como alguém que
investe no que realmente importa. Não é
só sobre aprender, é sobre pertencer ao
ciclo interno de quem está mudando o
jogo. Poucos têm a coragem. Será que
você tem?
Agradecimentos especiais aos nossos
membros queridos dos estudos avançados
da comunidade fechada no YouTube, José
Fortunato Marinho, Fernando Machado, Sou
Juciuli, Cristina Carol, Romana Moraril,
Estela Mares, Eloterapias Integrativas,
Saúde e Antes da Doença. E eu agradeço o
coração pelo apoio prestado.